came on how do you bring diversity
without losing its identity and
authenticity that's a great question I
think I think you came over what what
you want to do is just think diverse
from day one and are better than
provider for there's a book I've
mentioned on a previous kind of blab we
did by an Irish Bonnie and it's a book
or what works and the reason why I got
kinda choked me is there's so many kind
of subconscious unconscious biases we
all have I think the first thing you do
como is to make sure you talk about it
so then I think the fundamental I love
that word authenticity because if you
talk about stuff you get it out on the
table whatever it is and then you can
you know dispassionately see kind of why
do I think that way or you know why
while we were just recruited in that
sort of stereotype or why you know how
we even place in the words on our
website or our social media because
because it's all these little elements
kind of join together to actually
attract an audience and then the other
thing I think really fundamental as a
leader on also transparent and then if
you plan diversity and right from the
get-go into your business I think it can
be a real competitive strength in the
long term and it builds an awesome
culture and a coach you'd be really
proud of and I think of us to be the
financial return to that other's time to
date on that but it just makes you proud
that you feel something very special
very sustainable and very diverse and
inclusive as well so so I think that
comes down to the behaviors there's a
whole loads of research as well that are
around kind of D biasing because reality
is you just got to acknowledge that
we've all got we both got biases we've
all got armed conscious and sometimes
very clearly subconscious preferences
and and the more we actually challenge
them ourselves
then the better world videos
entrepreneurs and leaders ah
and the more actually we feel
placing and comfortable probably the
more we kind of fester and just progress
so I would really say memo said this is
what probably evident I do kind of most
weeks we reflect kinda what's gone well
what's not gone well what have I done
well as a leader did I did what could I
have done differently you know and then
kind of challenge is sort of
subconscious about you know weird viewed
these folks and actually it's kind of
great entities now I very often go to
meetings where I'm the only guy and I
think why this is cool like this and you
know I obviously it's way more than just
gender I've got to get into race faith
age disability all these areas but you
know I think there's some real real
things that you as a leader and
entrepreneur can kind of think about and
your rights have flagged up those words
of authenticity I think it's all about
culture it's all about transparency it's
all about good I think a great culture
is a company where people talk about
stuff people don't hide stuff or stand
by the you know coffee machine and just
talk behind your back
I just think transparency and openness
is a great culture because because
ultimately then you can put teams
together squads together who can work on
stuff that means stuff will change for
customers and build value for customers
is all about you know serving the guys
who are going to be buying a product or
services and really enjoying what you
build it building taking your idea and
making it real and the way you do that
is almost as important as the idea
itself so I think I think you hit on a
really rich reign there as you came oh
thank you if you're worried about you
losing your authenticity you need to
know what your mission is and you can't
I have diversity around a mission like
this is what our company is here to do
right like sage is here to help
entrepreneurs as long as you're
surrounded by that common mission then
there's a lot of different ways to go
and do it
right sage you know you guys launch your
your foundation which does a lot of work
around the world helping out Stephen
these to help out and give back
entrepreneurs they have sage summit
every year which is a massive party how
to help entrepreneurs and so there's a
lot of different ways to do it right as
other ideas that will come up as new
people come into sage and it even comes
up some ideas the way Bill attacks will
be a lot of different ways but there's
still the mission that we want to go out
and help entrepreneurs and build the
best software to do it you know we're
not in the car business or something
else I think as long as you have a
really focused mission you know you're
why look this is what we're trying to do
there's a lot of different ways to go
and attack it but not being I think if
you have diversity and the what we're
trying to do then that could be an issue
I think you need to have as the leader
how's that clear focus and then that
gives your team the freedom to go up and
do what they need to do